اذا اكثر من معطى اليوم في اكثر من مكان
داخل اوكرانيا معنى لمناقشه هذه المعطيات
العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي الذي ينضم الينا من بيروت
اهلا بك سياده العميد اذا نحاول ان نفهم
ما يجري استعمال الطائرات المسيره بهذه
الكثافه الان ااه 30 طائره في كياب ومناطق
متفرقه ايضا
همم اليه تفعيل همم
تكتيكيه اليوم
كل هذه المعطيات اين تضعنا في اطار فهم
الصوره الحاليه لما يجري
ليلى انتقلنا في هذه الحرب الى مرحله
الروتنه من روتين يعني قصف المسيرات هو
على قدم وساق المهم اليوم عوده المسيرات
وكان هناك مزيد من المسيرات ان كان من
المصدر الايراني او ان كان من المصدر
الروسي والهدف دائما هو اسقاط اوكرانيا من
الداخل
وعدم جعلها قادره على خوض الحرب او حتى
دوله قادره على العيش اليوم ما يجري على
الجبهات هو استمرار لشيء يحصل استعدادا
للمرحله القادمه صوره المرحله القادمه
ليلى تحدث عنها الرئيس جيلنسكي رئيس
الاركان وزير الدفاع وحتى القائد العسكري
حتى زياره الرئيس بوتين الى بلاروسيا هي
جزء من سوره المرحله القادمه التي قد
نراها ليلى
الرئيس يتحدث عن باقي ما تحدث عن
بيلاروسيا عن الحدود وركز على كلمه الحدود
يعني منذ اشهر ونحن نسمع عن غزو بري من
بيلاروسيا هل هل اقتربنا من هذا السيناريو
ام هو مازال سيناريو بعيد عن الواقع
احداث المحتمله هو صعب
زين لماذا لانه هل من سيهاجم من الجبهه
البيلاروسيا هل هو الجيش الروسي هل هو عدد
كافي ام ان الجيش البيلاروسي هو الاساس
الجيش الروسي جيش متواضع وعندما نتحدث عن
هجوم من بلاروسيا نتحدث عن الواقع السياسي
داخل البلاسيا نتحدث عن طول جبهه تقارب ال
1100 كيلو متر وسيكون الرد الاوكراني حتى
من ليس كما الرد على الداخل الروسي قد
يكون على عبر قصف منسف كما على سبيل
المثال للحصر يعني فاذا نحن امام مرحله
جديده معطياتها بدات تظهر مؤشراتها بدا
تظهر ولكن اليوم يجب ان ننظر الى ميليتو
بول الى ذا فولوجيا والى ما يجري في محمود
ما عدم القدره يعني محمود ليست مهمه بهذا
القدر الا لتسجيل مصر بعد الانسحاب من
خلال زمان يعني اذا اردنا نتوقف
تصريحات زنسكي اليوم هو يقول يجب
الاستعداد لكل السيناريوهات ربما هذا
الشيء ليس جديدا ولكن هو اا يتحدث عن وضع
متزايد في التصعيد هل هذا برايك
سيحفز الجانب الاخر على المزيد من التسليح
ام الباب الان اصبح مفتوحا اكثر من اي وقت
مضى على همم ايجاد حل السلمي الى اين ترى
المسار همم برايك
ليلى الحل السلمي بعيد لان الافرقه لا
يزلان على الاهداف الكبرى يعني الرئيس
بوتين يريد كل اوكرانيا والرئيس جلنسكي
يريد تحرير كل اوكرانيا من الوجود الروسي
اليوم المرحله القادمه خطاب الرئيس
جالينسكي هو لعدم ان يرتاح الغرب الى ما
يحصل
تسليح مرحله جديده نتحدث عن البتريوت
مؤخرا الباتريوت نسام الايريس وبالتالي
المرحله القادمه هي مرحله التحضير لحرب ما
بعد الشتاء والتحضير لحرب الدفاعات جويه
مهمه كي فعلا تستمر اوكرانيا في قدر على
القتال على الجبهات وهذا امر مهم جدا خاصه
البتريوت نقله نوعيه ليلى شكرا جزيلا
العميد الخبير العسكري ولسه استراتيجي من
بيروت